[Música]
mi nombre es akío morita
nací en nagoya japón estudié física de
telecomunicaciones y cuando terminé la
carrera
japón entró en la guerra del pacifico
bombardearon los míos
el hubble y me destinaron a varios
frentes evidentemente yo no sabe aquí o
morita ni me no parezco pero era un
profesor mejor dicho era un invitado en
una universidad no espera que nos está
haciendo una foto un profesor que nos
habían invitado a la conferencia una
universidad norteamericana donde yo
estudié y donde yo empecé a hacer mi
tesis doctoral sobre innovación
tecnológica
tal es así que íbamos por las tardes a
escuchar conferencias y una de ellas era
camarita que un señor que llegaba con un
traje y raído viejo con una camisa vieja
y nos contó esa historia y al final como
fueron perdiendo la guerra iban a lanzar
como kamikaze eso nos contó en una bala
contra en un proyectil contra un
portaaviones norteamericano cuando él
iban a lanzar declararon la paz después
de estos dos ejercicios pro derechos
humanos que hicieron los norteamericanos
en hiroshima y nagasaki que ocurrió que
se fue deprimido a su casa y su mamá le
bajaba valium y le bajaban pues
aspirinas o pitas y él se dedicó a hacer
ingeniería inversa [ __ ] un transistor
es un invento norteamericano como casi
todo y luego desmontado y montado
el primero se lo regaló a su madre
segundo su padre el tercero a su hermano
y al finalmente una compañía que se
llama la morita company yo aluciné con
él me encantó era un innovador un
compañero mío de esa universidad
una versión norteamericana que tiene 32
premios nobel el lotería del rector de
la computada se enfadó conmigo porque
dije 32 premio nobel 32 más que la
universidad complutense de madrid
es que no tenemos financiación de la
comunidad autónoma de la presidenta
al final me dijo mi compañero alemán me
dijo eso no es nada es una innovación
estúpida mis a mi abuela cogía la
corteza del sauce era rascaba idea y
sacaba una savia del sauce alemán que si
te dolía una rodilla te la lava mezclada
con leche y se te quitaban los dolores
pero qué interesante luego vine a españa
haciendo mi tesis doctoral sobre
innovación tecnológica de la que les
quiero hablar bien a españa y la
asociación de jóvenes empresarios me
llevaron a una sala donde había jóvenes
empresarios y uno de ellos era un
zangolotino porque tenía una rasta en
unas fábulas zapatillas viejas melena
con una coleta no era de podemos y
entonces estaba así y me dice que aquí
te dedicas y dice estoy terminado mi
tesis doctoral sobre ingeniera de
telecomunicaciones y que has montado de
montar una empresa de diseño por
ordenador
cuántos empleados tienes somos dos
socios nada más cuántos clientes tienes
uno veo pena mi país los que damos yo
soy profesor de macroeconomía en la
facultad de ciencias económicas y lo
sabemos que los ciclos las ondas largas
que inventa un ruso que se llama
kondratieff hay fases de expansión fases
de recesión fases de depresión fases de
expansión fases de recesión fases de
depresión y porque se producen
al contratiempo no era un jugador del
lokomotiv era un economista ruso lo dijo
demostró que la variable que generaba
esas asociaciones era la inversión eso
dijo un economista británico poco
conocido que se llama queines dijo es la
variable histérica de inversión usted lo
sabe los españoles perfectamente usted
no consume en la mitad si hermanos son
capaces de producir tres millones de
pesos vacíos y después no producir
ninguno entonces la inversión sube sube
sube sube sister y acá y eso me genera
es que genera los golpes de inversión a
largo plazo
yo buen economista austriaco no
confundir con la escuela austriaca yo no
hablo de religión
hablo de economía y llega una economía
sostengo y sebas un petter y demuestra
que los golpes de inbesós se producen
por las innovaciones tecnológicas
cuando innovaciones tecnológicas hay
expansiones cuando deja de haber
innovaciones teológicas hay depresiones
y recesiones y mi pregunta es mi país
está preparado para hacer eso es
importante en el marco de la diversidad
hacer eso mi país está preparado para
hacer eso vamos a comprobarlo más o
menos algo de memoria porque no tengo
los datos en la mano
españa invierte en investigación y
desarrollo un 12 por ciento de su pib
algo parecido a la media de áfrica
alemania un 3% austria un 3%
y otras naciones de la unión europea un
2,2 por ciento mucho menos
cuando se descubre cuando se inventa el
condensador frío y separado de la
máquina de vapor por untar james bat es
el inicio de la revolución industrial y
la fase de crecimiento económico más
acelerado nosotros fuimos son como
deciden en los libros de historia
económica unos las converse los últimos
en llegar por lo menos llegamos a una
uefa
quiere dar y starter el reino unido-
después francia bélgica también alemán
ya somos un país innovador que podemos
fomentar crecimiento económico la verdad
es que no somos un país que nos hemos
quedado atrás y nos podemos quedar atrás
sobre todo porque vienen grandes
paradigmas tecnológicos analicemos los
últimos 30 años al haber invertido
tampoco en investigación y desarrollo
tampoco por cierto entre paréntesis
conozco una investigadora contra el vih
de un hospital muy importante de madrid
que cobra 1.200 euros mil doscientos
euros contra el vih en madrid acaba de
venir de parís tampoco andan muy allá
pero invierten bastante más yan y más de
por ejemplos últimos 30 años lo que
llamamos los economistas la
productividad total de los factores es
decir cuánto producimos más por máquina
por personas ha aumentado en los eeuu un
30 por ciento en términos reales
en alemania un 20 por ciento en españa
un 5 por ciento
con eso no podemos pagar la seguridad
social con eso no podemos hacer muchas
cosas somos un país que nos vamos a
trazando es verdad que seguimos en la
uefa pero nos vamos a trazando es muy
importante invertir en investigación y
desarrollo para favorecer al mundo para
mejorar nuestro bienestar para generar
valor añadido yo acabo de llegar de
haití en haití el 40% de los niños no
tiene asistencia sanitaria en haití el
40% de los niños no tiene
educación 50 los niños ha sufrido algún
tipo de abuso y ahora innovaciones
tecnológicas que no pueden llevar a la
prosperidad hay grandes paradigmas
tecnológicos como dice el profesor josé
luís cordeiro por aquí presente grandes
paradigmas tecnológicos y grandes
trayectorias tecnológicas el exo cortex
google está investigando ponernos una
nube la mente el genoma humano nos va a
impedir padecer muchas enfermedades ya
está ocurriendo y no estoy siendo julio
verne estoy siendo un científico ya está
ocurriendo el parkinson está
estamos muy cerca del parkinson otras
enfermedades no vamos a lanzar la
esperanza de vida que estamos haciendo
nosotros hay que ser humildes como akío
morita que era un industrial humildes
humildes como por ejemplo
aquel que se quería ser famoso es
importante el otro lleva por el santiago
bernabéu al lado de la castellana vivirá
un señor y me dijo que viene a los 30 y
con una señora que viene a los 30 de
visión como me gusta que bien se expresa
y que muchas gracias señora adiós señor
marwen da
no uno no solo tiene que tener creído lo
importante lo importante es la humildad
y la ambición o es que acaso emilio
castelar cuando hizo su primer discurso
defendiendo la ley de abolición de la
esclavitud en la primera república no le
criticaron
yo he leído los discursos de la primera
república y emilio castelar decía hay
que abolir la esclavitud igual que yo
digo que con los nuevos paradigmas
teológicos podemos a morir la pobreza
en defender que hay en haití no se pase
hambre es decir hay que abolir la
esclavitud cuando decía eso saltó un
diputado conservador en los alrededores
del congreso vamos entre las bancadas
dijo cómo ser adoptado en emilio que
usted nunca ha tenido esclavos
evidentemente no había tenido esclavos
pero sabía que tenía que ser ambicioso
para abolir la esclavitud tenemos que
ser ambiciosos como país
innovar diseñar investigar difundir
gestión ser más ambiciosos estamos
entretenidos en otras cosas que no
vienen atrás en ellas pero ya saben
cuáles son las portadas los periódicos
españoles no hablan de innovaciones
tecnológicas ezz para eso hay que ser
bastante humildes y para eso hay que ser
bastante ambiciosos muy ambiciosos akío
morita terminado diciendo
vi como en un hospital una señora
llevaba una radio arrastrándola y le
pedí a la enfermera que me dejara poner
un alambre y un transistor inventé una
cosa que llame work band
un norteamericano me dijo si usted llama
a los transistores morita no va a vender
ni uno en eeuu y como le llamó y
recomendó el nombre que le recomendó fue
sony
ese señor con el traje viejo en la
universidad dónde yo estaba con la
camisa vieja con gafas redondas como
japoneses e kamikaze ese que había
nacido en nagoya era akío morita el
fundador de sony tenía sólo 250.000
trabajadores alguien da más 250 mil
trabajadores a gran game por aquí que
levanten la mano quien está enamorado
los casados también pueden levantar la
mano
por cierto
les hablé de mi amigo que he cogido la
corteza del sauce hubo un investigador
que sea hoffman que investigó porque las
abuelas alemanas se acaban corteza del
sauce para quitar el dolor y descubrir
un ácido que sea un ácido
acetilsalicílico trabajaba para una
pequeña farmacéutica deliver cursen que
hacía esquina con la calle hoffman que
se llama el mismo hoffman y la compañía
pequeña farmacia se llamaba bayern
inventó la aspirina por esos mayores
valles por eso son nelson y eso somos lo
que somos y mí sin embargo mi querido ex
alumno que estaba allí que había sido
estado haciendo la tesis doctoral y que
debía con las zapatillas viejas
zangolotino y que teníamos todo
trabajador un solo empresario le dije un
solo un solo cliente dije que el cliente
tienes y me dijo la disney
y dije [ __ ]
y cuanto facturas al año y me dijo tres
millones de euros ya no está en españa
viven los estados unidos y yo le dije
cuando me dijo te millones de euros
[ __ ] combate un ataque unos zapatos
[Aplausos]